Elizabeth Warren is now the leader of the
2020 democratic presidential primary in an
average of recent polls.
This is not my opinion.
This is Matt.
Bernie is more progressive.
Bernie more decided Lee
wants money out of politics.
Bernie more decidedly wants Medicare for all.
But this is a program that deals with what
is.
So we are going to discuss what is and now
what people who email me, uh, want it to be
will become very, very clear over the next
24 hours that I can assure you.
So listen, no, the polls aren't all biased
and done with only landlines speaking to people
over 80 years of age.
Okay.
I still have people emailing me, stuff like
that.
No Tulsi Gabard or Gabbard.
However she says her name at this point.
I know people keep telling me it's different
things.
She is not about to take the lead in the primary
as some people are still emailing me and saying,
this is down to Biden, Bernie and Warren,
and yes, Elizabeth Warren's rise has been
slow and steady quicker lately and she is
now the front runner, admittedly still within
the margin of error.
Let's look at the numbers first, which in
many ways actually resembled Barack Obama's
trajectory back in 2008 we'll look at that
in a second.
You will notice that from about April through
early September, Elizabeth Warren was slowly
but surely climbing.
Then we had an inflection point right around
the middle of September and the last three
weeks have been explosive growth for Elizabeth
Warren.
I will talk about why.
Don't worry.
If we go back and look at the 2008 democratic
primary and Barack Obama's eventual win, you
also see an inflection point where Barack
Obama's gains became a sort of more acute
and accelerated.
But that inflection point happened later in
the primary.
It wasn't until January of 2008 where we saw
that inflection point.
Now, of course every race is different.
Anything could still happen, but these are
the numbers today.
Now let's look at the recent polls that make
this up.
If we look at what are now the last 10 polls,
Elizabeth Warren leads in six of them.
If we look at the last five, Elizabeth Warren
leads in four of them.
So what do we think is going on here?
Things, there's a few things to touch on.
Number one, um, there is disaffection with
Joe Biden that is helping Elizabeth Warren,
a plurality of Biden supporters say that Elizabeth
Warren is their top second choice.
So when Joe Biden has bad performances and
they've been bad lately, when Joe Biden's
campaign is just low energy, it's not good.
That helps Warren more than any other candidate
because Warren is the top second choice according
to the latest morning consult poll for Joe
Biden voters.
That's number one.
Number two, and this is sad.
I mean I wish it weren't this way, but again,
I'm trying to deal on the program with what
things are rather than what one might want
them to be.
Bernie's heart problem at least correlates
with Elizabeth Warren's gain.
You might remember that last week Bernie Sanders
had his heart incident.
Uh, the same day actually that I developed
acute appendicitis and ended up in surgery
October 2nd and from October 2nd through today,
it has been a decline for Bernie Sanders.
You hate to see it, but I'm telling you what
the numbers say and that is a decline for
Bernie that correlates with the, uh, heart,
uh, condition, the heart situation, uh, circumstantially
at least it does seem to have effected at
least some voters.
Number three, and I think this is what maybe
many of you are waiting for me to say.
It cannot be denied that to some degree corporate
media would much prefer if it's going to be
one of the Progressive's corporate media would
prefer that it be Warren over Bernie.
And we know why.
I mean I've, I've, I've not hidden this from
you.
Elizabeth Warren is a much safer version of
modern progressivism to the system then would
be Bernie Sanders.
And so as Joe Biden has faltered, not only
are Biden's supporters already predisposed
to go to Warren as their primary, most preferred
second choice, uh, you have also seen that
as no one else stands a chance.
No one's even pulling 6% right now.
That has been a move on corporate media.
To talk more about Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders, I was looking at some of the coverage,
a numbers recently, a lot of the nighttime,
uh, cable news or, or rather network news
channels, the half hour news, they are covering
Elizabeth Warren significantly more than Bernie
Sanders.
And I think it would be naive to think that
that does not have an effect as well.
So this is where we are today.
Now I know that there are lots of people in
my audience who don't like it and I it right?
Bernie is stronger on health care.
There was no question Bernie is stronger on
money in politics.
Those are two really big issues.
The one upside here is if you are a Bernie
or Buster, uh, and ultimately you have to
settle in some way even if you don't vote
for her.
But if you have to settle for Elizabeth Warren,
it's not the end of the world.
Okay.
Like I, I know that there a lot of clicks
and money in online media for being unflinchingly
pro or anti this or that, but that often makes
bad policy and it blinds people.
And I don't want to play that game.
Elizabeth Warren has many faults.
It is not the end of the world if it ends
up with someone who can defeat Donald Trump,
uh, for it to be Elizabeth Warren rather than
Joe Biden.
Right.
Although there are no quote there, no question
that on many issues, Bernie Sanders is a stronger
progressive.
That being said, uh, number one, it's not
over.
Uh, this is just where we are right now.
Bernie could well have a resurgence.
And next I'm going to talk about what it might
take for that to happen.
Uh, but the other question at a certain point
is going to be one of electability and there
are a range of opinions about whether Warren
or Bernie would be better positioned to defeat
Donald Trump.
There is one really strong case that, uh,
suggests Bernie would be better positioned
to defeat Donald Trump because Warren will
ultimately be framed very similarly to Hillary.
Even if Warren is obviously more progressive
than Hillary, she will end up with a very
similar public persona and we will have a
repeat of 2016 that is an argument for Bernie
being more electable.
An argument for Warren being more being more
electrical electable is that while some of
her policies are not as decidedly progressive
as Bernie's and as unflinchingly progressive
as Bernie's a, she will be seen as more of
a pragmatist who may actually be able to make
her positions a political reality and that
that may be appealing to some voters.
I'm merely telling you that there are stories
to be told on both sides about electability,
which we will ultimately get into for sure.
Many we'll be paying attention to next week's
debates to see how is Bernie looking, what
is the dynamic between Bernie and Biden and
Warren, and that's actually the next thing
I want to talk about and I think that this
is going to be a very important conversation.